you've just had a kid yes
um
do you think that's changed you I know
from serving from afar and from a bit
closer it feels like you've been changed
massive how has that changed you do you
think it's changed your politics yeah
the pregnancy was very difficult um
it changes you completely I mean
actually does but um uh I I I have a I
know it I'm a different person now I
really am
um I I've become the person I used to
hate actually uh you know the parent
that goes around telling everyone to
have kids I've become him
um the future is not an abstraction now
it has a face and it has a name and
um I think quite a lot of the stuff that
we're talking about now comes from the
fact that we're not having children as
early we're not having them uh as
frequently uh that we are disconnected
from you know only a person who lives in
a world that is exclusively online could
say something as moronic as there's no
difference between men and women for
example right uh and part of the the
answer to that comes from seeing
children but I also think the thing that
it's brought home to me where you know
I'm not known for my conciliatory nature
but it has made me a little bit softer
in in the when you look at a baby you
see human potentiality in them and you
realize that everyone you're talking to
was one of them once and
um you know the desire to reach them is
stronger as a result
um so I I as I it's all wanky stuff but
I I feel uh much more connected to
humanity as a result and more most
importantly I recognize that
uh you know we live in a society I said
this when I was uh on Tucker Carlson
show we live in a society in which
adults are afraid of children
and I to me that is I mean there are
many irresponsible things that we're
doing in terms of our kids passing on a
huge debt as a country and so on and so
forth but the main one is we're not
providing them with the structure and
guidance that all children need to
thrive and so when I think about my son
I I I'm thinking about how to provide
that without going too far another
Direction and being authoritarian and so
when I think about woke people I don't
actually blame them for being woke I
mean some of the economic realities of
our society facilitate that on the one
hand and on the other hand my generation
I'm just about a millennial and a
generation after us we've been back yeah
geriatric Millennial yeah uh We've we've
been very badly let down by and Jonathan
height you know obviously he's talked
about this by adults who refused to be
an authority figure for us that we
actually needed and so the you know
having children forces you you to
confront that thing and it's made me
therefore I think be more responsible
person out in the world as well because
that's what I'm thinking about